Você sabia que o seu cérebro começa a
encolher fisicamente à medida que você
envelhece? Isso é um fato biológico. Mas
aqui está o dado que a maioria não
conhece. Um estudo divisor de águas da
Universidade de Oxford descobriu que
essa atrofia cerebral pode ser
desacelerada em até 53%.
53%
usando apenas três nutrientes
específicos. Isso mesmo. Mais na metade
da perda de massa cinzenta pode ser
evitada. Agora, pergunta de 1 milhão de
dólares. Se você fizer seus exames de
sangue hoje, é bem provável que seu
médico diga que está tudo normal. Mas na
minha clínica eu vejo todos os dias
pacientes com esses exames normais que
já estão esquecendo de colocar a chave
do carro ou perdendo o fio da meada numa
conversa. Nesse vídeo eu vou te mostrar
exatamente quais são essas três
vitaminas no complexo B, porque as
formas sintéticas que vendem na farmácia
podem ser dinheiro jogado no lixo e qual
é o nível ideal que você precisa buscar
nos exames para realmente brindar a sua
mente? Esqueça o normal. Vamos falar do
ótimo, que é o que você quer.
Para você entender como proteger sua
memória, primeiro precisamos falar sobre
o que está destruindo ela. Imagine que
suas artérias, seus neurônios são como
canos lisos e perfeitos. Existe uma
substância tóxica que o nosso próprio
corpo produz chamada homocisteína.
Pense na homocistena como uma espécie de
lã de aço ou uma sujeira abrasiva que
circula no seu sangue. Quando ela está
alta, ela arranha a parede dos vasos e
ataca os neurônios. E qual que é o
resultado? O cérebro inflama e com o
tempo encolhe. É a tal da atrofia. Na
visão funcional, a gente encara a
mocisteína como um dos marcadores mais
importantes de longevidade. Se ela está
alta, o sinal de alerta está vermelho,
berrante. E por que que ela sobe?
principalmente porque faltam os
faxineiros do corpo. O processo de
limpeza dessa toxina se chama metilação.
Eu sei, o nome parece complicado e se
você quer ver um vídeo sobre esse
assunto mais antigo, tem no canal. Coisa
de aula de bioquímica, mas pensa na
ventilação apenas como a equipe de
limpeza que varre essa sujeira para
fora. Sem essa equipe de limpeza, o lixo
acumula. E quem são os chefes dessa
equipe? Exatamente as três vitaminas que
vamos detalhar agora. Antes de eu te dar
a lista, eu preciso que você entenda
onde 90% das pessoas erram e onde muitos
profissionais de saúde deixam passar
batido. É a armadilha do intervalo de
referência. Você pega seu exame de
vitamina B12, por exemplo, o laboratório
diz que o normal é entre 200 e 900, aí o
seu dá 250. E o que que acontece? Você
recebe um carimbão assim de normal, você
vai para casa achando que tá tudo bem.
Gente, vamos cair na real. Uma B1250
pode ser suficiente para evitar que você
tenha uma anemia grave ou caia duro no
chão, mas não é suficiente para otimizar
otimizar a função cerebral. O cérebro é
fominha, ele precisa de abundância e não
de sobrevivência. A mesma coisa como
sistema. O laboratório diz que até 15 é
aceitável, mas os estudos mostram que
acima de 10, idealmente acima de sete ou
oito, o risco de problemas vasculares e
cognitivos já começa a subir
drasticamente. Então você quer que a sua
homoistena fique abaixo de 10 e por
volta de 7 o então aceitar o mínimo é
brincar de roleta russa com seu futuro
cognitivo. Então, na visão integrativa,
na visão funcional, nós não queremos que
você apenas não esteja doente, nós
queremos que você esteja
maravilhosamente bem, que você voe
baixo. Então, quais são os três
mosqueteiros que baixam essa mostína e
protege o cérebro? Anota aí, porque a
forma química faz toda a diferença. Não
adianta ir na farmácia e comprar o
polivitamínico mais barato de A Z. A
primeira delas, eu acho que vocês até
pensaram qual é, né? vitamina B12, mas
não é aciano comobalamina. Então ela é
essencial paraa bainaha de mielina, que
é o isolamento elétrico do seus nervos.
Sem ela, o pensamento fica lento, dá até
aquele nevoeiro ou nva mental. E o pulo
do gato, a maioria dos suplementos
baratos, usa cianocobalamina. É uma
forma sintética, barata, difícil de
absorver. O corpo tem o trabalhão para
aproveitar isso. O ideal é a
metilcobalamina.
Lembra da metilação que eu falei antes?
Essa forma já vem pronta pro corpo usar.
Então, temos que ter um alvo nos exames.
Na prática clínica, gostamos de ver a
B12 acima de 500 ou 600 picog por m. Se
estiver abaixo de 500, converse com o
seu médico sobre reposição. E o próximo
item é a vitamina B9, mas não é o ácido
fólico. Aqui tá uma grande confusão. B9
é crucial, mas o ácido fólico, que é a
forma mais comum, é sintético. Muita
gente tem uma alteração genética chamada
mutação do MTHFR.
MTHFR
que impede o corpo de transformar o
ácido fórico na formativa que entra no
cérebro. Então você toma, toma, toma
ácido fólico e não funciona e ainda pode
atrapalhar. O ideal busque pro
metilfolato ou eletrofolato. Essa é a
forma que realmente atravessa a barreira
hematocefálica e faz o serviço de baixar
homocisteína. O terceiro item é a
vitamina B6 na formativa que é a
piridoxina perridoxal 5 fosfato, tá? é a
terceira peça. A B6 ajuda a transformar
cisteína em coisas boas, como a gluta
que é nosso principal antioxidante do
organismo. Então, a forma piridoxal
cinco fosfato na sigla P5P é a forma
ativa. Em muitos casos, a perridoxina
comum funciona, mas o peridoxal 5
fosfato 5 P5P é a Ferrari das B6. Então
o estudo Vitacog usou doses robustas
dessas vitaminas para conseguir aquele
resultado que nós comentamos no começo
do vídeo de 53% de proteção. Isso não é
mágica, pessoal, é bioquímica pura. É
dar ao corpo a matéria-pra ele se
consertar. Agora você pode estar se
perguntando, Dr. Alan, eu já tomo o
complexo B e minha B12 continua baixa?
Aqui entra o segundo pulo do gato que
separa os amadores dos profissionais.
Não adianta jogar combustível de
atitivado se o tanque tá furado. Então,
para absorver B12, você precisa de um
estômago ácido. Isso mesmo. Se você vive
tomando antiácido paraol da vida, para
queimação, ou se você tem hipocloridria,
que é o nome técnico para falta de ácido
no estômago, que é muito, muito comum
depois dos 50 anos, depois dos 40 anos,
você não absorve bem a B12, por mais
cara que seja a vitamina. Então, o ácido
estômago é necessário para separar a
vitamina da comida e prepará-la para
absorção. Então, antes de sair comprando
portes e portes de vitamina, você
precisa garantir que a sua digestão está
em dia. E também pode usar na forma
sublingual. Também é uma maneira de
passar por cima do problema.
Às vezes o tratamento pro cérebro
começa, na verdade, no estômago.
Recapitulando, cérebro encolhendo não é
destino, é muitas vezes falta de
nutrição. Homoisteína alta é o inimigo.
B12 na forma de metilicobalamina, B9 na
forma de metilfolato e B6 na forma de
P5P. São os heróis. E os valores de
referência do laboratório, use com
desconfiança. É melhor mirar do meio
para o limite superior, ou seja, o
terceiro e quarto quartis. Mas como
saber se você tem ácido no estômago
suficiente para absorver tudo isso? Eu
fiz um vídeo explicando um teste caseiro
simples para saber se a sua digestão
está te sabotando. Você precisa assistir
ele agora para fechar esse ciclo. O
vídeo vai aparecer aqui na tela. Mas
antes de você clicar, saia do vídeo
agora se você gosta de ficar
superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade muito inconveniente. A
plataforma aqui e o conselho me limitam
a que eu preciso simplificar, censurar
dosis e omitir alguns protocolos
considerados controversos. Na minha
comunidade fechada não tem esse filtro.
Eu compartilho exatamente o que eu faço
na minha clínica, casos de reversão que
aparecem como impossíveis, combinações
ofel que funcionam e fornecedores
confiáveis, além de interpretação
avançada de exames. É basicamente ter
acesso ao meu cérebro médico sem
intermediários. Nós temos lives semanais
respondendo perguntas, PDF com 47
protocolos exclusivos e o grupo no
WhatsApp com gente maravilhosa para
discutir a medicina e a saúde funcional.
Se você quer a visão funcional real, sem
simplificação para massas, clique em
seja membro e não é para qualquer um, é
para quem quer resultados. Agora, se
você quer ainda mais fundo, tem o nível
dois. A cada duas semanas, nós temos
lives de imersão total com 2 horas de
duração, de secando artigos científicos
linha por linha, debatendo controvérsias
que ninguém ousa tocar, revelando os
bastidores das pesquisas que a indústria
não quer que você entenda. E tem mais,
seu nome será mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você torna a parte
visível dessa comunidade de elite que
está reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste passivamente,
você estará do meu lado construindo
conhecimento de verdade e tendo o seu
reconhecimento público como alguém que
investe no que realmente importa. Não é
só sobre aprender, é sobre pertencer ao
ciclo interno de que está mudando o
jogo. Poucos tm essa coragem, você tem?